[Music]
so welcome to this this final session of
the of the very parallel discussions
that we are having are having discussion
here with my good friend David about
well we have an official title are there
physical facts or only interpretations
that sounded the very kind of post
postmodern view on science right but
we're gonna take the pre modernist point
of view so you are here in the
proponents David I want to start by you
talk this morning about the scientific
methods the various elements in the
scientific method observations
experiments theory one of my favorite
cartoons has two scientists is a very
complicated lab and they say all very
well colleague this all works does it
also work in theory and because I want
to be in the end to say nature is the
final arbiter of truth but it's also
something about the nature of truth know
what's how do we describe it and what's
the role of theory and so can you
perhaps you say a few things about what
it means to be a theorist because I
think up to now a lot of the discussions
about facts which are just the data
points but we do much more than just
data points now we draw a curve through
all in the end of science is to
understand to understand exactly well
two things to understand to satisfy our
curiosity that know how and and
sometimes why it works but the other
thing of course is to control yes we
mean I think ever from an evolutionary
point of view scientific method after
many faulty turns that was discovered
and process it was so effective that it
evolved rapidly because it enabled
humans Homo sapiens to control
that are in better the physical world
and you know destroy other species for
example and change the earth and kill
other humans and so on so there are two
goals understanding and controlling but
and for the scientists understanding is
so important of course that's but this
is this understanding sometimes a
painful process so for instance if you
look in our field particle physics
now think of our say quantum mechanics
you know we now celebrate as a great
success but it was a kind of painful
delivery and in some sense it also led
to the loss of certain things for
instance the fact that we couldn't
perhaps predict or understand certain
things that we wore and date for some
people it's still very painful yes
personally I don't find it painful at
all but you know some of my great heroes
like Einstein was tortured by the change
of world view that quantum mechanics
required and could never accept it I
mean the fact that there's only
probabilistic statements and and you
don't have this
yes eyes image of how things you know
it's a little more complicated in that
and and in some sense the quantum world
is totally deterministic you have a
deterministic equation for for the
evolution of States in a Hilbert space
however in order to discuss measurements
and how we how we make contact with the
observable world we are forced to
introduce statistical statements yes
it's a change of point of view still one
that 90 years later quantum mechanics is
still very young I don't think we fully
deeply understand in a way that will
probably take another a few hundred
years cut deep concepts in physics take
a long time to assemble to truly grasp
so indeed being forced to
change one's fundamental concept is very
difficult difficult and politics it's
difficult in family life it's it's very
hard to change one's point of view yes
we all know that change one point of
view about some of the basic concepts of
our picture of the world which we
acquire as infants exactly I think we're
actually now today in modern physics
going through a period which might last
another century of truck um into grasps
with the quantum nature of space and
time our most basic physical concept
right and we're trying to modify that
we're being forced by our attempts to to
go beyond our present theory and to
confront some of the mysteries of
gravity and quantum mechanics I believe
to change our basic concepts of space
and time that is a very difficult
process it is currently painful
especially since we don't know the
answer yet actually so just talk about
also this I mean one thing but we of
course try to do is to know discover
more truth you know expand our
understanding you mentioned this morning
a few of the kind of fundamental
questions about now how did the universe
come into being a question about what is
the true nature of space and time yes
these are questions that you know
previously wouldn't even be considered
questions well I'd like to say that you
know in the path well questions like
that we were simply we didn't know
enough to be ignorant yes we didn't know
enough to be able to formulate question
my favorite again a scientific way my
fate example you know if you would go
back a hundred years yeah any any
question about anything around us no why
is glass transparent no why have thinks
the colors they have why does the Sun
Shine questions that a young child will
ask yes they were all basically
unanswerable right because we didn't
have atoms we didn't have molecules and
we couldn't calculate any of the
properties of any material around us
right and it's interesting in fact when
you go back to scientific literature of
a century ago or more most scientists
didn't
ask those questions no because they sort
of know you know they didn't know how to
approach the school they were just so
slow they weren't yet scientific
question yes so but the realm of what is
scientific questions has grown
enormously many of which we answered
like what is life yes I'm here that's
amazing we now know what life is we're
not exactly sure how it began on earth
but we know what it is or the origins of
you know the the cosmological
irregularities I would say that's your
the formation of structure in the
universe yeah it's totally science is
remarkable
so can we briefly talk about what is
kind of the the compass that guides us
into this kind of an ocean of ignorance
No so again you know some for some
theorists it's it's mathematical beauty
I mean it's the console what's the role
of mathematics to your point of view
well I regard mathematics in much like
language and logic yes the same you know
it's simply the mental tools we have
acquired evolutionary to comprehend the
real world they're kind of basic it's
hard to change logic nobody very much
except some of our crazier colleagues
have imagined different universes with
different logic mathematics yes so there
are tools but we have that they are
tools that I believe developed because
we are trying to control the natural
world some people find it surprising
that they work so well rather than
actual world I don't because we
developed those tools to describe the
natural world no but is it is it really
weird if they didn't work is it obvious
that you know one thing that you know
you and Frank and others here are we are
context of the standard model particle
physics which is amazingly powerful
theory it's I find it extremely elegant
yes no it can fit even the mathematical
equations can fit on one line was there
any guarantee now clearly you say well
this obvious that mathematics in some
sense describes the world that it is in
some sense so simple well you know I
if you try to analyze what do you mean
by mathematical beauty yes so you know
if I write down the equations of quantum
chromodynamics I find them beautiful you
find the beautiful Frank fights and
beautiful I'm not sure why your taste
isn't acquire is an acquired taste but
it's more than that what do we mean by
beauty yes in mathematics this kind of
elegance that you're referring to I
think it you know my impression when I
met when a mathematician says an
equation is beautiful I I think some
extent what do they really mean by that
it's the power is that it's powerful
yeah so beauty first approximation at
least mathematically is equal to power
and that's sort of what we mean in
physics as well I mean one of the
amazing facts that you know we our
discovery led to was this theory which
was unbelievably powerful you know we
now can an infinite number of
predictions out of that you know just
the power of a simply formulated set of
equations and concepts with this
enormous applicability and that's in
some extent what we mean by beauty but
I'm not it's not really surprising if if
science what again
I don't find it totally surprising that
the world is comprehensible hmm I would
find it pretty bizarre if it wasn't yes
would that mean yes so it's not too
surprising but it but I do admit that
it's just absolutely wonderful and
gorgeous
well it's perhaps not surprising that
it's in at some level comprehensible but
isn't it kind of surprising that for us
human beings who are you know we have a
limited brain
it wasn't evolved to understand quantum
chromodynamics it was evolved to survive
in the jungle or something and we are
able to do this anyhow right it is kind
of amazing we are somewhat of a
primitive species which our politicians
are are exhibiting yes
what we have going for us is the thing
you start out with it with it was
mathematics and language so what
differentiates us from those from our
cousins whom were busily exterminating
is the facility of language whose most
advanced form is mathematics and that is
a powerful tool with somewhat of an
infinite capacity a newborn infant can
utter sentences that no one has ever
uttered right or so we have kind of an
enormous leap powerful tool well one
thing we have seen this with such you
know the story of science is also very
much a story of transition through
somehow move to a next level
I think fine and somewhat surprised it
very nicely that they said you know well
everything fits and then certainly
something doesn't fit and you think oh
wait a moment this is a crisis and then
by somehow going to the next level
probably sometimes also by losing some
you you gain new insights and then
becomes beautiful again in the way like
quantum theory is beautiful but it's at
different level as quiet I think I still
don't agree with you that we lose
something yeah we lose something that
was incorrect or wrong wave so something
to lose yeah it's a good thing to yes
because it really wasn't didn't work so
well so it's not a bad idea to lose bad
ideas but yeah it there might we might
run out of the ability to do this who
knows we're trying to you know we now
phrase and can write scientific papers
and get them published in good journals
about the beginning of the universe
yes that's looks like a pretty hard
question to solve I'm not I I hope
they're good answers in my lifetime I
kind of doubt it but it is a scientific
question now are we smart enough to
answer such a question I have faith that
we are and if not we'll start modifying
is or having intercourse with machines
or who knows what can I just a point to
that point out I mean in some sense no
the big big story these days is no
machines getting
smarter some Somali from many fields of
science you know where they are
confronted with massive amount of data
we have machines making sense of it you
think if that will be at some point part
of our effort to find the truth will be
you'll be interviewed here or I I do
think we will evolve to have a very
interesting relationship with machines
and in one way or another but I think at
the moment the all this discussion about
deep learning and so on is a lot of hype
mmm it really is enormous ly exaggerated
and those those neural networks that
have have done quite a bit you know are
able to play go and Jess are are not
very interesting my opinion and are very
unlikely to discover anything
interesting one thing I worry about this
is that it's all about training machines
to understand data and patterns so
they're very good kind of understanding
a certain fixed universe of phenomena
but I think the human mind has this
wonderful ability to jump out of it well
and we are no idea versions what the
human mind is or how it works
yeah the weirdest thing is that these
machines or neural networks that learn
how to play go better than go masters
the people who construct them and
they're sitting there before it right
you know right there and you can measure
every component and how it's connected
every other component of those neural
networks people have absolutely no idea
how it works either yes so we don't
understand even how the machine works
much less the human brain I'm just very
not impressed by the accomplishment so
far and and not to speak of the things
they can't do right
can I move to some completely different
subject so so you talked about you know
the this morning
basically equating truth is a scientific
method and so if we talk about you know
spreading in some sense not the perhaps
the facts of science but the methods of
science so I want to share a little
anecdote that was on television and
showing little experiments that you can
do with children so I had a little
balloon filled with water you can do it
at home and you try to with the light or
trying to burn a hole in it and it
doesn't work and so you can do the
experiment I should have done it here
and it's absolute drama and then you can
explain a little bit why this happens
because has to do with the heat capacity
of water so I had a nice little spiel
there and the next morning I got an
email from a very famous Dutch scientist
and he said I loved your presentation
but your explanation was totally wrong
you didn't show the experiment to
explain anything about heat capacity and
thermodynamics you did the experiment
because you showed that you can trust
science there was a law of nature that
prevented this magic trick from going
wrong so this is really about can we in
some sense explain the scientific method
because I feel this really attention by
explaining the latest results in science
which might be very complicated
only few experts will understand it but
as you said in the scientific method is
much more it's a way to understand the
world it's something you can apply in
various walks of life so how can we kind
of teach the method in instead of just
focusing on the results it's a wonderful
question and I certainly don't have the
answer I'm a little distraught by the
fact that you know we have improved math
education yeah this last century you
know essentially ago very few people
received anything beyond elementary
education now most of our citizens
united states Europe you know advanced
countries finish high school and yet
scientific ignorance in numeracy
and superstition astrology believe at
least especially the United States
belief in creation is yes continues even
with half perhaps you we could argue
that the where Segoe or hundred years
ago it was easier for scientists to
advise politicians and policy makers
probably in other word they had a more
direct communication than nowadays yes
so nowadays I think it was more
immediate nowadays it's all magic so or
you know everyone uses these devices but
number one no I'm sure 99 percent
including me based I mean have no idea
how this is made or couldn't fix it
Felix the radio they couldn't that be at
this this is could be a dystopia that I
worry about yes which I would say that
on the one hand you know science
progresses it becomes very complicated
if no idea how your iPhone works you
have no idea how the medicine works that
you're taking if Noah we are how did the
machine that's controlling your life
works and on the other hands so it
totally ignorance another hand you
totally control by it yeah or that could
be in in some sense we are deploring
here the way the public and politicians
appreciate facts but science is
progressing technology is not slowing
down and we are really in the grip of it
right it's very it's contradictory but
we certainly are losing this direct
touch with as you call experiment yeah
tactile connection that people used to
have with chemistry sets and and fixing
the radio or the car you can't even fix
a car anymore yes but and and so what
happens is that people of who might be
attracted to science or interest in how
things work now go on to the computer
and and get seduced by a digital world
that is unreal I mean the other day a
kind of a computer program it was used
for children to learn about mechanics so
you could put like your hat there are
two weights and then the computer
simulation showed how they I think wait
a moment
program any law of nature you actually
should do the physical experiment and
see it with your own eyes I mean I'm not
sure how you ever develop physical means
you know as theoretical physicists we
were all required to take an
experimental lab that was really painful
yeah it was painful but boy was it
important you actually feel how things
work and but maybe there is a kind of a
glass half full theory here that you
know what happens with the spreading of
education or something that no people
might have turned into somebody called
it like proto scientists so you talked
about the natural skepticism
again this is phrase you know belief in
the the ignorance of experts your mind
fineman's famous phrase that people are
they taking some of these approaches for
instance no the the proof by
intimidation like a hundred years ago if
you were a professor you would declare
something and everybody would you know
would believe it because you were the
professor these days I'll throw in some
countries in some countries still true
but it's probably that's a losing fight
I think these days will never come back
but so in some sense that people have at
least a kernel of a scientific or
skeptical attitude it's that's something
that we could work with we encourage
that on the one hand yes and the other
hand we also like to exert scientific
Authority so science I mean I I
mentioned in my talk that there's no
authority except nature yeah it's not
completely true since my fear you know
they're around this world of science
there's a vast world of pseudoscience
yes and we we have all sorts of
institutional protections that separate
science from pseudoscience and and they
work pretty well and do require a
certain amount of authority but its
authority that can always be questioned
and yes so so one thing that you know I
worry about is that you know we have
this enormous growth of the scientific
edit surface you know the architecture
we have really the number of scientists
is growing incredibly fast
the number of collaborations is growing
very fast there's a lot of policing
going on yes but you know little bit
reflecting on the earlier discussion an
infection at one place could easily
spread right isn't that something you
worry about that you know if there's
some major disaster in the scientific
world that people start doubting all
science we have strong
we have strong a strong immunological
system that we've collected so far
protects us from pseudoscience by and
large it's very decent idea I'm not sure
but yeah I suppose it could happen
progress if you look human history or
recent human history of the last ten
thousand years definitely shows us that
progress is not always positive yes we
should remember that in the days of
Trump yeah there were there was this
period from the end of the Roman Empire
for a thousand years of the Middle Ages
yes where indeed we lost our
understanding of science of scientific
method of mathematics and if it weren't
for those monks in Ireland a lot of the
lore or the Islamic culture which means
yes one thing you said I want just to
finish we were getting to the end so you
you end it you're with a kind of a slide
that was saying we will be in the end so
Churchill in power right but part of
that I think has been which is terrific
I think you know that we have this kind
of global system we said science is a
fact universal it's very hard to imagine
any topic we can talk about if aliens
lands to your very lives right now very
importantly we unlike the beginning of
the Middle Ages we have a single
language of science yes and luckily it's
not that
[Laughter]
actually in the 17th century there was
one Dutch scientist Athena thought that
actually Dutch was the language spoken
in paradise I will explain you in a
moment why that's why he felt compelled
to have Dutch brought all the scientific
inspired gods to pronounce it correct so
let's finally talk about this this
element that you know we we are an
international community and I think
that's something very very rare right
when I don't think we have any had
anything before where there is a culture
that's you know spread around I think it
has a universal language it might have
been English you might also argue it's
mathematics and that creates some kind
of stability our shared calls to a
shared language and you know I often
think if somebody were to ask me like
this your person from Mars landed on
earth and say which country are you a
citizen of I would say I am a citizen of
science that's beautiful
yes I want to enter way over time one
last question okay I'm giving you a
magic wand and there's one fact one
elements that everybody in the world
will understand after you wave your
magic wand what will it be
I mean after QCD after QC what would you
pick
aha I hate this kind of question let me
give you my favorite one okay
the scientific method Wow good okay
thank you very much well done